hey what's up guys my name is shauna
welcome back to another hazel devlog i'm
standing today because what can i say i
am excited also kind of inspired by
randy with the whole standing thing if
you guys have not seen the latest
channel podcast by the way i'll have it
linked up there you can also listen to
it on spotify if you want to clean the
house while listening to a podcast like
i do all the time so why am i so excited
today i mean how exciting could ui
possibly be well turns out pretty
exciting so up until now we have not had
any like ui capabilities in hazel itself
like obviously the editor ui exists like
all the buttons all the kind of text
that you see on the screen all the
panels all of that is done through imgui
that's all great but for in-game ui
meaning like if you actually make and
ship a game and you want it to have any
kind of user interface not just like
hard elements but also like a menu
screen and maybe like a score kind of
somewhere you want text rendering you
want layouts you want all of this
complex kind of behavior if you want
more information about what really uh
kind of falls into the ui category of a
game engine then definitely check out
the let's talk video i made recently
i'll have it linked up there as well
that is basically covering everything in
a 2d game engine and of course ui isn't
just for 2d game engines also very
necessary for a 3d game engine so on
sunday i i had a full week of
like actual development work for hazel
planned out lots of
exciting and also non-exciting things
that just have to be done as far as the
engine goes but on sunday i was like you
know what i'd really like to be able to
render some text
how hard could that be now for those of
you who haven't done any kind of text
rendering i'll probably get deeper into
the technical details of that when we
actually start doing that for hazel 2d
for the game engine series because i'm
gonna have to implement all of that but
long story short it is fairly
complicated and i mean there's two parts
to it there's physically rendering the
characters of text but then you also
have to like know where to render them
make all of the kind of geometry on
which you're going to render like those
actual characters know how far to
advance the characters all these like
font matrix things but then also like
layout and like you know do you want to
like left a line in your text write
align your text so ui in general is very
complex and i'm not really i haven't
really gotten to that stage yet in what
i've implemented here so far but the
text rendering is basically in there's a
few different ways to actually
physically get those characters like on
the screen i mean i think early like
back in the day they used to make like a
font atlas like a sprite sheet basically
like a texture atlas of just different
characters that were like in an image
file so you could kind of use basically
photoshop or paint or whatever to just
like write the letter a b c d e put them
all into like one sheet i mean you could
even have them as separate textures if
you really wanted to maybe have like a
pixel rasterizer kind of software-based
renderer and that that way like
different textures wouldn't really be
the biggest like problem in the world
whereas obviously with opengl and with
like directx with
vulcan all the gpu rendering apis we
prefer to like minimize the amount of
textures we have so we pack many
characters into like one texture and
create like a texture outlets but
ultimately you could do that and then
when you want to render like a
particular character you just look at
the texture you find the sub region in
the texture that you that you need for a
particular character so you get those
texture coordinates and then you just
render a quad that is you know
appropriately sized basically with those
texture coordinates and you have your
character so that's like kind of phase
one phase two is reading a font file
instead of that so if you read a font
file you can dynamically create that
texture you don't have to do that
offline in in photoshop or paint you can
just kind of you know load a font and
then be like i want these characters
maybe i want to render like the text
churno on the screen so i need like a
capital c then h-e-r-n-o
right those are the characters i need i
can request that from the font file
which contains like mathematical kind of
you know curves that define those shapes
and then i need to rasterize them into
pixels which i can then store in my
texture i need to record like where i
store each character so that i can then
retrieve those texture coordinates and
then there you go i can render my
textured quads again this is turning
into a bit of a fun tutorial anyway long
story short the previous method that i
kind of just mentioned
that was that's it's not bad like it's
it's fine but the problem is it's kind
of common for you to want a little bit
more information about the actual font
characters not just for like you know
doing various effects like if i want to
add like an outline or a glow or a drop
shadow or something like that but like
even for something as simple as i want
to be able to render my font at
different sizes
if you just have a rasterized like
glyph
then you can't really scale it up it's
going to get blurry around the edges or
it's going to be all pixely i mean think
of scaling an image up in photoshop if
it's like i don't know if you guys even
use photoshop but if it's like a smart
object or if it's something in
illustrator you can scale it up to any
resolution because it's all kind of
mathematical but then if you rasterize
it and it's just pixels scaling it up is
a nightmare so
it's still not kind of ideal
enter signed distance fields sdfs are
they're just so good they basically
allow us to store a little bit more
information about the actual glyph that
we're rendering not just like here are
the rasterized pixels but also kind of
which way they head in so that we have
an idea of like expanding outwards in a
particular direction and by doing that
we have the ability to well basically
scale it up to any size because when we
actually physically work out which
pixels to render which pixels should be
part of the glyph which pixels should be
fully transparent and maybe even a bit
of anti-aliasing to kind of make it
smoother as it fades from being in the
glyph to being not in the glyph when we
actually rendered that textured chord we
can do all of that in a pixel shader in
a fragment shader instead of having to
like rasterize the already kind of ready
to go pixels up front and that in
general is so so so powerful as i'm
about to show you in a minute now did i
write all of these like sign distance
field functions and like generating
those sign distance field kind of
textures from font files and doing all
that no i did not instead i use this
brilliant library by klumsky or chlumsky
called msdfgen this is absolutely
brilliant i mean it's a multi-channel
sign distance field generator he's got
various kind of different ways of
generating distance fields so there's
actually quite a few options i'm not
sure if this describes it all but if you
actually go through like the
documentation the source code all that
you'll see all the different like uh
types of like sign distance field glyphs
it can actually generate it basically
can also pack that into sections for you
there's another repository he's got i
think it's just up here called msdf
atlas gen which actually will generate
an atlas like this now oh here we go
here you can see like the different kind
of you can have just a normal hard mask
you can have a soft mask sdf psdf msdf
so like with multiple channels and stuff
like that and an empty scf like there's
a lot of kind of work that's gone into
it i think he actually did this for like
his thesis or something like that for a
master's degree or even like a phd or
something so it's really really cool
it's mit licensed so of course it's
absolutely amazing so this is what i
have been using to make that make all of
that stuff happen inside hazel now at
the moment this stuff is all working in
hazel like in in hazel 3d and in
patreon.com hazel but eventually this is
like a great example of the kind of
stuff that will make it back into the
game engine series into hazel 2d because
of course it's very much necessary to
also implement in a 2d game engine you
want text rendering in it
in any engine really but the great thing
about this again is just the the level
of quality you can achieve from text
rendering i mean it's it's really
satisfying to get really nice crisp text
rendering especially you know this is
especially important i would say not
even for ui but if you want text to be
in your 3d game world because if if
that's the case then what if the
character like what if the camera walks
up to the text like and crashes into the
wall and is reading it like this close
you know like
you you're going to need a gigantic font
size and if that's like pre-rasterized
that's going to be an absolute nightmare
anyway
but that's not all our audio guy jay yes
love i've talked about him before
because he was kind enough to just
introduce a brilliant audience system
into hazel
he has decided to completely
redo hazelnut's ui yep
our audio guy i'm beginning to think
he's secretly interested in ui but it's
just too ashamed to admit it or
something like that anyway long story
short hazelnut looks absolutely
incredible now so those are the kind of
the two things i want to show i want to
show you what i've done so far over the
last three days i've only spent like two
or three days on this font stuff nowhere
near done like with the ui side and the
ui system of hazel so to speak but i'll
show you what i've done and we can also
take a look at the absolutely amazing
new hazelnut ui so coming in over here
this is what we're greeted with i've got
just like a blank project running let's
get rid of this so this everything you
see here um has basically been re-kind
of done from the ground up i mean even
things like these beautiful shadows you
see here like the attention to detail
here is absolutely
like amazing i wouldn't expect anything
less from jay because he's just he's
just such a such a great kind of i don't
know engineer artist audio musician
uh person but basically like this is
kind of the look that we see here
it's all kind of uh you know it all
works as you would kind of expect it to
work we have like this custom title bar
it says like the name of the project up
here i'm not sure if you could see that
before because of the face cam trying to
kind of keep it um
you know visible but this is basically
what it looks like now the scene
hierarchy has also been completely
redone as we'll see as we start to
create some text elements so how does
this work well we can just create text
just by doing this but another way
obviously is if we create an empty
entity i've integrated this with the nc
component system so i was going to just
do it for like 2d kind of ui and stuff
like that first but i don't know why i
just decided you know what let's just
chuck it in like into like the 3d world
as it's as if it's like an entity and
already like so that we can use it in
projects in games because for a while
now i wanted to be able to like annotate
scenes um and you'll see how i've done
that in a minute here but basically if
we make an empty entity and then we can
add a text component to it and that will
just add this thing here now of course
it isn't in 3d space like this we've got
a few options here and again this is
like a couple days of work so i'm sure i
will add more stuff like you know
outline options and whatever but
basically at the moment we've got like
this kind of multi-line text entry where
you know i could just type in like hello
my name and i can hit enter is churno if
i wanted to drop down or i can just
write it all on one line like that
i've got a few other controls that i can
play with such as color so i can you
know change the color of this make it
whatever i want uh there's line spacing
which you'll see in a minute kerning
which of course is just like the kind of
horizontal distance between characters
and then you kind of saw it take effect
there we have a max width as well so
it's actually in meters it's it's how
how much text we're allowing to fit onto
like uh one i guess horizontal line so
if you reduce this then it's going to
basically try and drop down words of
course if it's too small then well it
can't do anything but there we go right
um we can kind of create like the
beginnings of a layout with this so that
was that was fun to do um and actually
zero is definitely not should not be the
default uh and then line spacing is the
vertical distance that we have between
lines if i hide the grid here so if i
play with line spacing you can see i can
just play with how the text kind of
lines up like that which is pretty cool
so this is um basically the initial set
of tools that we have oh and of course
we can like reduce the alpha it's all
kind of blendy which is really hard to
see but if i maybe make a skylight or
something
you can see how it's kind of blending in
with the background there
as opposed to being like solid white
like this now what about font size i
hear you ask what what font size there
is no font size if you want bigger font
you just scale it up and you can see as
i'm doing this that there is absolute
like it's just sharp like it's it's just
going to be sharp because of the way
that it's rendered um so it's really
really cool um to kind of have this
uh like i i just love this stuff so much
because it's just you know it's not even
like me as an engineer being like this
is just so cool it's me as like a user
of this being like wow i don't have to
consider font sizes like it's just so
it's just it's just great honestly um so
let's kind of uh grab this and scale it
down again
um what else is there okay yeah so like
what about like stress testing it a
little bit there is so much stuff i want
to do for optimization again this is
just like early days but if i get like
some kind of like um lorem ipsum kind of
uh generator let's copy like this
massive paragraph here from my other
monitor and just chuck it in here um
maybe let's make the max width a bit
larger um then you can see like i mean
this is huge and it's obviously still
running at 60fps it's very smooth but um
can i even like fly faster
here we go there's a bunch of text here
right so in terms of the way that it's
rendering it is very fast i don't think
you're ever going to need this much text
on the screen especially because we
don't have any kind of culling right
there's no camera kind of frost and
culling or anything like that there's
the end um it just all it's actually all
being rendered every frame which is a
little bit dumb but that's kind of what
we have i wish there was a way to reset
actually if i just hit f there we go i
can focus back on the top um
yeah so that's kind of that's what we
have at the moment uh oh and finally you
can also change the font right so i've
got i've got a font here um this is just
like some kind of handwriting font i can
just drag that in over here and it will
actually generate those um
uh it will actually generate like an
msdf texture file on the fly um and
that's what we see here
uh but you know if you wanted to be like
you know what's the process of adding a
new font well let me show you it's
really easy
i'll just right click go show an
explorer this is the actual um like
location of it of this ttf file then if
i go to see windows fonts i can find a
font that i like um such as
well let's go with what's like a cool
font
what's a cool font file i feel like i
have barely any fonts on this computer i
did wipe it recently actually um okay
let's just go with like some kind of
monospace cool one like gonzales maybe
let's go ahead and copy that paste it in
here well lots of ttf files
uh we can go with like a nice i think
this is an italics one yeah sure let's
go with this one so if i come back here
hit refresh drag this one in here
and then you can see now i'm i'm dealing
with that new font right so the workflow
is really quick of course this is stored
as an asset as like a fun asset inside
hazel so we can access it that way
um i'm kind of running out of things to
say so use cases for this i mean apart
from just i want text in my scene in my
game
if i go and open like another scene file
here so let's go ahead and check out the
uh the prefab sandbox because i added
some um stuff to that oh wow the camera
doesn't seem to uh
to reset or anything but you can see
that in this scene um like i've been
able to write some text and then for
people who actually open this stuff up
uh you can see like a little bit of a
description so once you hit play you can
left click to shoot glowing green cubes
if we actually do hit play you can uh
actually see that obviously this text
exists in the game world um now it's not
rend it's actually rendered
later like after all of the passes so
it's not affected by bloom it's not
affected by
uh lighting at all this is like a
separate 2d pass that's done as like
kind of
well in in like deep in the hazel code
it's like done during the external
compositing pass so that's where you can
kind of overlay elements i've done it
there so far it is still depth tested
and everything because it uses the
actual depth buffer from the main
geometry pass but it just kind of
composites on top of the final kind of
color buffer of our scene so that's kind
of technically where it sits in the
pipeline which means that yeah it
doesn't like it's not gonna you know
it's not gonna be in front of like
certain things right well i need to be
careful if you hit a green cube with the
green cube like if the two green cubes
collide then they release those kind of
orange
orange things let's see if i can make
that happen there we go
anyway so point being
um you know it's nice to be able to kind
of annotate scenes and just like show
different effects maybe different
materials like hey this is an emissive
material these are the parameters it's
i've wanted to do this for a while i
think it's great for people using like
the engine and trying to learn and stuff
like that but also just i guess for fun
and also you'll notice if you're cool
that we also don't we don't just support
english um so if i was to make a well
let's just duplicate this prefab sandbox
one um if i uh which one is it this one
um i can just go ahead and like let me
just type like pdf or something i can
type in uh you know in this case
cyrillic kind of characters so russian
in this case um what else we've got some
wild characters in russian where's your
user personal favorite no my favorite
one is ya obviously because that's the
first character of my name
um your as well we have like an umlaut
um on the e here uh yeah so we kind of
support all of that um there's even i'll
put like a screenshot of japanese as
well it's just that a lot of fonts don't
actually support japanese glyphs like
they just don't have them so you need to
have like a special font file that
actually supports japanese glyphs which
i don't have at the moment but yeah
that's basically like
i guess everything that i've done in
terms of fonts at the moment so the next
step is probably going to be uh doing it
actually like in screen space in 2d
space instead of just in like a 3d world
like that
it's very very similar with how it's
rendered there's some extra kind of math
that happens to determine like how these
distance fields should actually get
rendered
you know if they're um
in 3d space because it's not like a
constant kind of i guess distance from
the camera it's
kind of uh you know variable like not
even just the distance but like if you
look at it at an angle like this as well
so there's like a bunch of like math
it's very simple that needs to happen
actually there's some examples in the
msdf repository did i mention i'll have
that linked in description below in case
you guys also want to kind of take this
and integrate into your engine uh again
i got this stuff working and to this
kind of pretty much polished state it's
been pushed to the master branch
yesterday so it's actually all kind of
there for you guys who do have access to
hazel to check out i got to that set in
like two days so it's it's really quick
i have done font stuff before in the
past uh throughout my life so i'm aware
of like how it should work um and
obviously we have like a you know a
batch renderer in hazel and all of that
stuff support for multiple textures
so we can actually support multiple
fonts all being rendered in a single
batch if we need to um in fact let's
kind of test that i mean you guys get
the point i don't know i don't have to
oh this is okay so yeah so if i
oh ctrl z actually works with i'm
gooey's controls which which is nice
considering we don't have it
um in the editor i'm still in russian um
but yeah like i can obviously go back to
fonts and like let's go with that
godzilla's one uh once they've been
loaded that kind of stay loaded so it's
very quick to like switch between these
but
that actually all gets bashed together
into a single draw which is pretty nice
as well
anyway thank you guys for watching hope
you enjoyed this dev vlog again lots of
exciting stuff those of you who do have
access patreon.com it's only 10 bucks a
month to help support this entire
project you will get access to all of
this you can check it out and you can
learn from it and also you'll be
contributing to the actual development
of hazel as well so it's amazing that
we're able to achieve so much i'm really
really grateful to the team as well lots
of them being volunteers of course who
are just volunteering their time to work
as part of this project i think that
like you know it's i mean it's already
amazing what we've achieved but there's
some really exciting stuff coming in the
future as well so yeah i'm just
generally excited right now thank you
guys for watching as i mentioned this
stuff will make its way back into hazel
2d fairly soon i think because ui i mean
ui is probably not that soon in hazel 2d
we still want to like do the i think
like the the 2d physics first and like
the c-sharp scripting and then maybe ui
at some point then but it'll be entirely
based on this current system so yeah
thank you all for watching have a great
day goodbye
[Music]
you